have a gun license plan to bring your
gun to my hometown next time you fly in
pack all unloaded firearm and firearm
parts and a locked hard sided container
you call the TSA they will tell you put
the gun in a locked container and
notified the airline during the ticket
counter check-in process but even if you
do this properly New York authorities
will still wreck your life I declared my
gun because I always do I travel I fly
in and out all over the US with it
Patricia Jordan carries her gun for
protection she correctly followed all
the TSA procedures when she flew from
her home in Georgia it's in New York
City it's in the TSA okay everything's
separate it's locked
she was traveling with three teenage
girls and one is her gun in her hotel
room I know that if something happens
that then I can protect myself I was
glad that she had brought it just in
case something did happen on their way
home Patricia did everything correctly
again the airline counter she again told
the agent she wanted to check her gun
but this time she was told wait the next
thing I know they're they're getting
ready to arrest me for what exactly for
having a gun I thought I was going to
pass out I really did I have my permit
I'm doing everything on the 15 right of
course I started freaking out she sit
there and begged the lady please don't
arrest my mom please don't arrest my mom
she was like crying begging her not to
take me the police put Patricia in jail
and told her you've committed a felony
the minimum was three and a half to
seven years mandatory prison for this
another visitor avi Wolff was jailed
just for having a gun part an empty
magazine there were no bullets it's just
something like this is exactly like that
instead of a plastic exterior mine had a
little bit of a different make to it but
it was exactly that somebody could have
done more damage to an individual with a
fork from McDonald's than with that wolf
- checked with the TSA beforehand they
told him just declare it to TSA agents
at security I'm telling them that
notification I have a magazine here it's
empty there's no bullets there's no
gunpowder it's you know I call TSA
before doing it I'm and this was a told
me to do was to declare it the next
thing I know they pulled me over to the
side and
they're all like do you know what you
have in your bag I'm like I know what I
have in my bag I told you what I have in
my bag fast for about an hour it was a
four for Port Authority police officers
are there the chief of LaGuardia Airport
is there like I mean they thought they
found somebody trying to do 9/11 repeat
this literally for that after you've had
a gun license of course I've had a gun
license and Georgia everybody there's
got a gun license now like well sir
you're going to be getting arrested now
oh my god no the other prisoners
couldn't believe why Abby was in jail
one guy beat up his wife this other guys
busted a whole bunch of drugs is it like
so what did you do what why are you here
so I I got caught at security with an
empty magazine what'd they say just
laughter is it joke but it was no joke
avi and Patricia were released after a
day in jail but they still face that
felony charge
I can barely function I had to get on
like anxiety medicine I was throwing up
every day months later New York allowed
each to plead guilty to a lesser charge
public disorder but it cost each $15,000
in legal fees why is New York City do
this to people they need to spend a day
in jail we get them through the system
as quick as we can District Attorney
Jack Ryan handles New York Airport gun
charges we're not going to apologize for
enforcing our gun laws we do enforce
them fairly and humanely and as
compassionately as we can is it a fair
system when it costs from fifteen
seventeen thousand dollars and they
spend a day in jail it's as fair as we
can make it under all of those
circumstances even in Abby's case it's
an empty piece of plastic whether the
magazine is made out of plastic Kevlar
or metal I think as in material to make
question of how many bullets at holes
that's why New York has banned them
isn't what's material is whether it held
any bullet it didn't it was empty you
can discuss that with the legislature
they didn't make it a crime only if
there's bullets in it they made it a
crime Patricia had carefully separated
her gun from her bullet the officer
could not even fine
not the case I had to stop and go over
the works but yet they said that this
was considered a loaded weapon in New
York in the New York law if they're
together
they're loaded and so we have prosecuted
a number of those even if they're not
loaded if they were empty eight and
weapon and the ammunition together
they're loaded most every week New York
Jail someone who innocently travels with
a gun legally licensed in their state
these are people are trying to do
everything right they go on the TSA
website they follow the regulations to
fly with their gun they go on the
airline website and they follow the
regulations to properly plywood their
gun and then New York jails them you're
a sadistic bully blocking these people
up these aren't threats we know they're
not threats after we check them out we
do not know who they are
when we first talk to them give me a
break prosecutors have discretion they
could be reasonable with these poor
people who had no idea that they
violated New York strange laws but New
York politicians don't want you to have
a gun so they will put you in jail to
send everyone a message
you